aquí tengo un cohete que va a lanzar un
proyectil quizás pase a una roca de
algún tipo con una velocidad de 10
metros sobre segundo y la dirección de
esta velocidad es de 30 grados por
encima de la horizontal
lo que queremos calcular aquí es qué tan
lejos llegó esta piedra entonces mi
pregunta es
lejos
llegó
bueno para simplificar el problema vamos
a descomponer este vector en sus
componentes horizontales y verticales
entonces vamos a dibujar este
esta parte será su componente horizontal
de este vector velocidad
y este será bueno de hecho lo puedo
dibujar aquí
este será el componente
vertical
entonces bueno
vamos a obtener una parte de la
velocidad que va hacia arriba y otra
parte de la velocidad que va hacia la
derecha la componente vertical la
usaremos para calcular cuánto tiempo
estuvo la roca en el aire ya que no
importa cuál sea su componente
horizontal pues el componente vertical
es la única que determina qué tan rápido
se desacelera hacia arriba por la
gravedad se detiene y vuelve a caer lo
lanzamos a una velocidad hasta la altura
que llega es la altura máxima en la que
su velocidad se vuelve a cero y vuelve a
descender hasta que cae al suelo
esto determina cuánto tiempo va a estar
en el aire y si conocemos esto vamos a
poderlo multiplicar por la componente
horizontal de la velocidad y entonces
calcular qué tan lejos lleno llegó de
nuevo asumiendo que la resistencia del
aire es cero de otra manera la
componente horizontal va a cambiar vamos
a resolver el problema lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es descomponer este
vector velocidad
como les había comentado en sus vectores
x en sus componentes xy
vamos a dibujar el componente i
aquí más fácil
aquí está mi vector
y barba vamos a calcular primero el
componente vertical conocemos conocemos
la hipotenusa que de este triángulo
rectángulo y es la magnitud
de de este de este vector velocidad pues
bueno corresponden con las funciones
trigonométricas
tenemos que este es el ángulo que yo
conozco y lo que quiero saber es el
cateto opuesto que es este el componente
vertical y conozco la hipotenusa de en
nuestras funciones trigonométricas
seno coseno y tangente
tenemos que el seno
es igual a
cateto opuesto sobre hipotenusa el coche
no es el cateto de ya sea entre sobre la
hipotenusa y la tangente es el cateto
opuesto sobre cateto adyacente para
calcular la componente horizontal vamos
a usar la función seno así que
vamos a tener
que el seno de 30 grados
va a ser igual
el cateto opuesto que es la componente
vertical
vamos a llamarle
velocidad a la magnitud de este
componente
velocidad
sobre
voy a hacer otro color más que ha dicho
sobre la magnitud de mi vector velocidad
que en este caso son 10 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado
y bueno a lo mejor ustedes recuerdan de
sus clases de trigonometría cuál es el
seno de 30 grados si no lo recuerdan
pueden usar sus calculadoras aunque este
es un valor fácil de recordar el seno de
30 grados es igual a un medio
vamos a dejar solo el término que
queremos conocer
si multiplicamos 10 metros sobre segundo
por el seno de 30 grados que bueno es un
medio
esto va a ser igual a mi vector
la magnitud de mi vector velocidad
10 por un medio la mitad de 10 vienen
siendo 5 metros sobre segundo entonces
este valor será igual a 5 metros sobre
segundo y esta es la magnitud de este
vector
esto mal
igual a 5 metros sobre segundo
ahora pasemos y pensemos cuánto es el
tiempo que va a permanecer en el aire ya
que tenemos una situación en donde
comenzamos en el suelo y terminamos
también en el suelo y estuvimos que la
resistencia del aire cero cuál será
nuestro cambio en la velocidad hablando
solamente de la componente vertical
cuál va a ser mi velocidad final
bueno comenzamos con una velocidad
vertical
aquí la ponemos vertical
y aquí de nuevo mencionó recordamos
nuestra convención de qué cantidades
positivas
indican la dirección hacia arriba y
cantidades negativas indican una
dirección hacia abajo
entonces tengo que mi velocidad inicial
es la que acabo de calcular
mi componente en mi velocidad inicial
es igual a 5 metros sobre segundos 5
positivos porque nuestra velocidad
inicial va hacia arriba
y cuál va a ser mi velocidad final bueno
comenzamos con cierta velocidad mientras
subimos vamos más lento hasta que
tenemos
hasta que nos detenemos por completo y
volvemos a caer acelerando hacia abajo y
ya que no hay resistencia al aire pues
vamos a caer ahora vamos a tener la
misma velocidad justo antes de dar en el
suelo pero en sentido opuesto en
dirección opuesta entonces mi velocidad
final vamos a ponerla en otro color
mi velocidad final
será la misma magnitud pero en sentido
opuesto menos 5 metros sobre segundo
queremos ver nuestro
cambio en la velocidad vertical
y esto es igual a mi velocidad final que
es mi velocidad final es menos 5
menos 5 metros sobre segundo menos la
velocidad inicial y en la velocidad
inicial es menos malo menos la velocidad
inicial que fueron 5 metros sobre
segundo 5 menos 55 pues va a ser esto
igual a menos 10
metros sobre segundo
menos porque va hacia abajo es la
dirección hacia abajo y cómo vamos a
usar esta información
sabemos que el cambio también el cambio
en la velocidad
en el sentido vertical va a ser igual a
la aceleración
en sentido vertical
por el cambio en el tiempo
cambio en el tiempo
conozco la aceleración vertical que es
la aceleración de la gravedad
entonces este valor
allí es igual a menos
9.8 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
menos porque va hacia abajo
este cambio de velocidad es el que
acabamos de calcular que es menos 10
metros sobre segundo y esto es igual
a la multiplicación de este valor por el
cambio en el tiempo lo que queremos
conocer es el tiempo entonces vamos a
despejar esta parte por lo que voy a
dividir ambos lados entre menos 9.8
metros sobre segundo por lo que me va a
quedar
menos 10 metros sobre segundo en tren
-
9.8 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado y
esto va a ser igual
a mi cambio en el tiempo
aquí bueno menos entre menos se anula en
estas cantidades lo que es bueno porque
queremos tener un tiempo positivo
realmente nuestro en nuestro mundo real
un tiempo negativo no tiene mucho
sentido así que es bueno que estos
valores nos queden positivos y si hago
esta división yo ya y le hice aparte
pero les invito a que ustedes utilizan
su calculadora para verificar esto esto
este valor este cambiar el tiempo va a
ser igual a 1.02 segundos
ese es el tiempo que se queda en el aire
este proyectil
y ahora cómo vamos a usar esto para
saber qué tan lejos llegó
ahora necesitamos conocer el componente
de la velocidad en sentido horizontal
así que necesitamos calcular este valor
este componente visual del cual fue la
velocidad en el sentido horizontal y de
nuevo vamos a usar nuestras funciones
trigonométricas
ahora
tengo que
esto quiero calcular esto que es el
cateto de aceite al ángulo entonces
ahora voy a usar mi función seno perdón
no el contrario vamos a usar el cateto
adyacente vamos a usar la función coseno
de 30 grados va a ser igual
a mí
cateto
adyacente que es el componente de la
velocidad en el eje de las equis esto se
llama b equis
entre la hipotenusa que viene siendo los
10 metros sobre segundo
ahora de nuevo este valor del coseno de
30 grados vamos a usar ustedes lo pueden
calcular con la calculadora nosotros
aquí en este vídeo vamos a usar su valor
digamos que no tan complejo el curso no
de 30 grados es igual a la raíz de 3
entre 2
así que voy a tener de este lado
esto que está dividiendo va a ir
multiplicando de este otro lado entonces
es 10 metros sobre el segundo por el
coseno de 30 grados al kasen o de 30
grados es raíz de 3
y esto entre 2
y esto va a ser igual
a mí
el componente horizontal del vector
10 entre 2 va a ser igual a 5 esto lo
puedo simplificar dejándolo
5 x raíz de 3
igual a esta
magnitud de x
y ahora ya tenemos cuál fue mi velocidad
inicial mi velocidad en el sentido
horizontal
metros sobre segundo y quiero bueno vaya
ahora voy a calcular el desplazamiento
el desplazamiento y obviamente en el
sentido horizontal es igual a el cambio
en el tiempo o la velocidad multiplicado
por el tiempo
tengo que es
en la velocidad fue d
5.5 x raíz de 3
metros sobre segundo y cuando tiempo
pasó fueron 1.0 2 segundos el cambio en
el tiempo entonces esto lo voy a
multiplicar por 1 punto 0 2 segundos
para calcular mi desplazamiento de nuevo
ya jce el cálculo pero ustedes lo pueden
hacer
con su calculadora y verificar estos
valores resulta que esto 5 x raíz de 3 x
1.02 es igual a
8.33
metros y esta es la distancia que
recorre en sentido horizontal mi
proyectil si éste lo pongo aquí la
magnitud
de este vector horizontal es igual a
8.33 a la sisla distancia que estoy
haciendo
ok ahora dadas para ver si ponían
ustedes atención en la magnitud de este
vector velocidad en el lado horizontales
5 x raíz de tres metros sobre segundo la
distancia el desplazamiento es de 8.33
metros en el siguiente vídeo veremos
otra manera de calcular esta este cambio
en el tiempo aunque sería un poco más
complicado pero va a ser mucho más
poderoso